going here's gosman's numbers on the
years making his 32nd start it's 14-6
with a 2-9 279 innings pitch 211
strikeouts it's pretty good and only 50
49 walks then the first pitch
jumping on it for a base hit to left
field
garrett hamson and he got a fast ball
and he was right on it two strikes to
count
to charlie blackman
hamson the runner at
second fastball struck him out 97 miles
per hour one strike to count runner at
second and the fastball
lifted high along the right field line
belt going out and belt makes
the
basket style one-handed catch after a
long run down the line
2-2 pitch is hit to third and it kicks
up off of mcmahon and rolls away that's
going to be a hit for solano
he's got himself a base hit
solano will go to second
and that at least will get grossman up
and not having to lead off the next
inning
and he puts him away
to end the inning
gaussman
pitches
and a splitter struck him out swinging
mcmahon goes down second gauzeman
strikeout one away as we see that pitch
once again
yeah that was nasty he's thrown two
really good splits so far in this game
all right rewind it with two strikes
one and two the count
struck him out
and i don't know if that was his change
up or the splitter but it worked
beautifully
and that might be the best pitch you see
at the about
well he does get a walk so he is aboard
the pitch he swings and lines one into
right center field base hit
one ball no strikes two men on nobody
out
this could be two
there's one
not in time to first
brad's got excellent speed so wade
moves over to third belt is erased at
second on the force out
rbi opportunity here for crawford with
runners at first and third
and the only player is the first as a
run scores so crawford
it may not be the way he wanted to do it
but it was effective weighed in to score
and bryant also moves up into scoring
position
gosman holding
now delivers and a swing and a missed
strike three got him with the splitter
bosman has four strikeouts
2-2 got him swinging with the splitter
so grossman gets his fifth strikeout two
down
here is yaskrimsky first ball swinging
diving stop story
that's a great play by trevor
that's to make this throw from his knee
too
once you catch it if you get that left
foot
or the right foot excuse me down and the
left knee okay you can come over the top
and make a strong throw just like trevor
did on the subaru super moc
here is
he hits this one to center field
shallow
and it's going to
fall
story couldn't catch it hamson couldn't
either belts trying for second and he's
in there
here is chris bryant to try and knock
him in
brian pulls that one into left field and
that's a hit
coming around third belt he's going to
try to score the throw is offline he
doesn't even need to slide belt with the
double
and then bryant knocks him in it's two
nothing giants
got him with the fastball 96 miles an
hour seventh gaussman strikeout
krohn's had an excellent year 27 home
runs
he blasts that one to left center field
and deep and it is gone there's the
first run of the game for colorado
his 28th home run of the year two to one
[Applause]
yeah see where casale's glove is he
wants it down and away where does it go
down and in and all crone has to do he
loves the ball down that's where he
pulls the ball for power is that down
and in pitch i think he liked it
3-2
he threw the fastball and he blew it by
him strike three slow him down with the
split and then speed him up at the top
part of the zone with a perfectly
executed fastball
one two got him with the splitter nasty
gauzeman gives up the home run but he
also strikes out threes
line drive and dropped by solano
and that's gonna allow hampson to reach
hampson will get the head start there he
goes 3-2 is hit hard into right center
field so blackman gets the hit wade's
got to get it in quickly with hampton
speeding over toward third let's see if
he can get back down below the zone
right here
he got him to chase great splitter and
that's about as much emotion as we've
seen from kevin gausman
he wanted that one bad no long balls for
them today
and that's a walk for wilmer flores
oh look out that hit him no no
that's not good for now he's staying in
[Applause]
back door
well done
this is going to be a base hit for cj
so the time run aboard
and it does look like wilmer flores is
now at first base for the giants
flores does not make the play
hilliard reaches
over the home plate
with littell being in the box son and
that's a buck a buck has been charged
now
no chance at a double play the jacks
infield comes in
halfway
solano goes home and he is out what a
tag by casalli the throw is offline at
cassani lunch back across and got
him yeah i'm not sure he tagged him
i know crone's saying the same thing
so they aren't
appealing this call let's see
see how you missed
it's right on the plate flat out misses
the tag and from what we've seen
i think there's a very good chance this
is going to be overturned
and there's the call
the call has been overturned
the rockies have tied the game
and he gets the walk
[Applause]
and he walks in on four pitches the
second walk of the inning
two men on one man out la stella trying
to knock in a run here to put the giants
back ahead
that's a base hit
blackman comes up throwing duggar being
set by waltus
and he's safe
diaz
had the ball
but apparently missed the tag and it's
three to two giants
brandon crawford stands in against
kinley
crawford
deep left field top of your back
adios pelota
and that is what they've been needing
and the giants fans at coors field are
going nuts
brandon crawford with the opposite field
home run
just when they
very badly needed it and suddenly the
one run game is a 6-2 lead
[Applause]
he struck him out the
road trip is over the game is over
and the giants for the second time in
the month of september have swept the
rockies in denver